music gets you through the morning run
it gets you through the drive to work
and maybe even the work itself
perhaps music is also getting you
through the pandemic for most of us
it's a reflex to find the songs that
suit the mood but for a small group of
local therapists
finding the right song means a whole lot
more
[Music]
we all use music therapeutically without
even
realizing it
this little life and the way that that
creates
you know a drum beat a bass line that
you know is the basis of everything
[Music]
little hazel's world moves at a
different pace she's surrounded by the
adoration of her parents
tubes and medicines and the relentless
sound of her ventilator keeping her
tiny heart alive so hazel
is our miracle baby hazel was born with
a brain disorder
no one knows how long she'll live it's
crucial to fill the time she has
with life two and a half years later
still kicking
bailey hins helps change the rhythm
every few weeks
she fills hazel's home with therapy she
you know has defied the odds and been a
little miracle
sing for all your friends we all like to
hear you hinz is a board-certified music
therapist one of the few in las vegas
music can help us to process
those emotions something that would
create
that sense of peace even if it didn't
help her like it helps
me and it helps her dad just kind of
um it's therapeutic for us
therapy at the start of a challenging
life hello hello
and at the end of another this is amory
care assisted living
everyone who lives here has some form of
alzheimer's or dementia and a happy
new year got your feet going i like that
if you play music especially from their
past
they seriously come to life and it calms
them down it
makes them feel at peace peace that's
been hard to find in a pandemic
when many of hinz's most vulnerable
patients need it more than ever
i was unable to be in person with any of
my patients
with end of life specifically it was
it was very difficult to not be there
with someone holding their hand and
providing that in-person
comfort made out of gold her patients
are fragile
frequently time is short yeah sweet girl
so she's doing something a little
different i continue to be
amazed by
just listening to the heartbeat hinz is
recording the music we carry inside
and making music hazel's parents can
cherish
forever it's something that is
meaningful to the family and they can
continue to
listen to this living breathing
person that they love long after
they are no longer with us
[Music]
it's just a song about love
and we love her our hearts
create music inherently they just do
it's bringing forth the the song that
i mean that's in in all of us
[Music]
so music therapy can be used not only
for end-of-life care or any other forms
of therapy it's also for
children with special needs adults with
special needs there's a variety of ways
if you're interested in this form of
therapy music therapy we're going to put
a link on the
state's website or from the state's
website on our website on the practice
it has information on it and links to
certified therapists all across the
state